Chop Chop it's less than a month to go
before Christmas
and newick's butchers in the Oxfordshire
town of tame is cracking on in Readiness
for their busiest period
Tom newett's family have been in the
food business here for over 200 years he
employs 20 staff and alongside the fresh
meat makes approaching 10 000 pies and
packets per week but the environmental
story we're doing here is not actually
about the meat itself it's about what
goes on Backstage all the freezing
chilling and cooking using so much
energy and where all that electricity
comes from
we have a lot of a lot of freezer units
um all of which we're building stocks
for for our festive period pork pie
sausage rolls are all big users of power
and this year he's using a different
power source
we're using a diesel generator
generating power to run the whole site
how come
purely down to financial and the cost of
pure cost really that the energy costs
are so high in order of us to be
competitive and stay in business we've
needed to save that huge chunk of our
overhead give me a feeling of how much
money or how much power we're talking
about here
350 000 pounds is our
forecasted energy consumption over the
air
and hopefully on a fair wind we should
be about a third of the cost by running
a diesel running our diesel generators
he had the generator anyway as emergency
backup but now it's running 24 7. and
getting through this two and a half
thousand liter tank every week I mean in
terms of environment and climate change
these things aren't great does that
trouble you at all it does and we are
doing things within the business
um having an electric van which I've got
on order and we've changed all of our
packaging over to uh reusable and oven
proof trays which are recyclable and all
of our packaging now is paper rather
than using Plastics
power generators are similar to diesel
engines in cars
gases and particles that cause pollution
linked to conditions like asthma lung
disease cancer and even babies of lower
birth weight what's really bad about
diesels is big particulates big chunks
of carbon and they're going up into the
air that we all live in and breathe
and when it comes to climate change
diesel generators pump out 17 more
carbon dioxide than the grid for every
unit of electricity when we generate
with Renewables like wind they just
don't generate any of these factors any
of these chemicals at all so you know
diesel is just the wrong thing to be
doing at this point in time when we know
so much and how to do things in a much
better way but the fear of blackouts and
the high cost of grid electricity
overrides any environmental doubts for
dealers generators are flying off the
shelves almost nothing is in stock it's
just to see a red out of stock out of
stock out of stock all of the similar
generator suppliers we spoke to reported
soaring demand unheard of it's everyone
that we speak to they just say it's
crazy we we can't keep up since we've
had these large energy hikes we've seen
both you know residential customers and
but predominantly business customers now
uh exploring options to run their their
businesses from their own power
generation equipment mainly industrial
diesel generators
more and more of our Mains electricity
comes from clean frequently cheap
sources like wind and solar but the
bills we actually pay have been
escalated by the gas shortage the result
business is driven to shop around for a
bargain even a polluting one